hello and welcome to the spectators
conservative party leadership hustings
i'm isabel hardman and i'm going to be
joined by the final three contenders in
this race to number 10 penny mordent liz
trust and rishi sunak now the contest
has got rather heated in the last few
days and so for health and safety
reasons we decided to keep the
candidates apart and actually grill them
on the substance of what they were
standing for so you'll hear first from
penny mordant then from richie sunak
who's joining us down the line
and then finally from liz truss
do enjoy
well thank you pennymordent for joining
us for our spectator hustings
please give us your one minute opening
bid to be conservative leader well i
think it's incredibly important that we
win the next general election and it's
important to win elections but the next
one is really critical because unless we
do we will not lock in all the benefits
that we have now having left the
regulatory orbit of the eu
we won't consolidate that position
labor or a labor-led socialist coalition
will drag us back in to that regulatory
orbit
and they will not be able to have the
vision that we have to respond to the
mandate that the people gave us for a
new direction for the united kingdom
okay thank you well let's move on to our
first topic which is the key dividing
line in this contest
tax cuts
do you propose significant tax cuts how
significant and how would you pay for
them
so in this contest i think that this is
not the place to be setting out a new
tax policy on things like corporation
tax
what i've chosen to do is focus on
growth and competition
clearly
next april on the current trajectory
rishi set us on we are going to be one
of the most uncompetitive uh nations in
the oecd
and that cannot be allowed to happen we
have to be able to compete so there will
need to be some changes but exactly what
and when is not the issue for that for
this contest what i've chosen to focus
on is growth because yes we've got to
tackle inflation but we also have to
tackle the weak demand in the economy
and through supply-side reforms focusing
in on infrastructure investment uh
incentives and innovation really
turbocharging the economy getting things
to really happen on the leveling up
agenda and we need to continue with that
and we need to increase it but i also
recognize the need for some immediate
targeted support so are you turning the
spending taps on is that what you're
planning to do so i think we need to
recognize that we're not going to be
able to slash government expenditure as
some early candidates in this contest
said because of the because of the
situation that we are going into we do
need to control expenditure i want to
focus on the things that are a priority
to people
there's lots of things that government
doesn't need to do that it's currently
doing but
we're not going to be able to make some
of the
cuts that other candidates earlier in
this contest
put forward what we do need to do
is to grow the economy and we need to
help people who are really in dire
straits so that's why i've got these
targeted uh measures to to really
support them it does sound to me like
you're heading towards higher borrowing
though
it's important that uh important that we
get our um
balance the books and get spending under
control we've come through obviously an
enormously difficult period where we've
been spending huge sums i have set out
one very simple fiscal rule i haven't
put others in place because chancellors
will end up breaking them
so we do need to
reduce our our debt but
we also need to recognize the very
volatile period we're going into and uh
so i'm not setting out uh
um any further fiscal rules um certainly
in this contest and that would be the
one rule that would cover
my administration just a monetary policy
is it the bank of england's job to
control inflation and if so do you think
it's doing that job well
so it is um i think that there certainly
have been issues having read some of
their correspondence that's come into
the treasury uh about their performance
in that respect but that is that is
their role i'm not going to change their
their independence in in
any way
but what we also need to focus on is the
weak demand in the economy as well and
that's what i focused on that's what the
supply side reforms will do
okay let's move on to net zero are you
committed to the net zero target yes i
am and the interim targets but i think
we have to change the narrative on this
and and change
slightly our approach
this has got to work for consumers not
just because it's
not good idea to clobber consumers but
because
unless it does it we're not going to
meet those objectives
the things that stop people getting an
electric vehicle are not because they
don't care about the environment it's
because they know they're going to have
to
change
what time they set off to go to their
place of work in order to recharge and
and come back it's very very practical
things so we clearly need better
products we need more innovation uh and
we need to also make sure that uh the
costs are tolerable uh for individuals
secondly this has got to be part of the
growth story and should be part of the
growth story
we could be creating
many many jobs out of this over the next
few years millions of jobs and higher
wage jobs so again we have to build that
into the narrative again
focusing on the the four eyes that i've
outlined will help do that and finally
and just explain those four eyes so
infrastructure
uh investment uh supporting innovation
as i've described and incentive so
really looking at
not just rewarding people for doing what
they were doing anyway but how actually
you you crowd in funds to particular
missions that you're really looking uh
to set up so we've set out to today in
the uh press uh some detail on what that
looks like and how we would facilitate
that at a local level
we need more powers at a local level we
need some fiscal devolution as well and
we need people to be able to grow those
wealth firms
funds
development corporations we we want to
uh introduce in certain areas uh to get
that really motoring to get the growth
back in the economy but just finally on
net zero the other thing that is really
really critical is and very important to
me personally is our is our national
resilience and security
i rewrote this country's resilience
strategy during covid and uh
net zero needs to be part of the story
in terms of that uh our energy security
uh and just really our our
ability to stand on our own in that
respect and that's why i was against
certain projects that would make us uh
vulnerable
now just on accountability on net zero
you're obviously planning to have a long
and glorious reign as prime minister but
chances are you probably won't still be
in power by 2050 so how are you going to
hold yourself to meeting the targets in
in the interim to ensuring that your
government while you're in power
is making the necessary progress rather
than loading that burden on to future
governments as is so often the case in
our political cycle so governments uh
believe it or not are not the are not
the answer to everything the real answer
to this is scientists innovators
entrepreneurs people who are really
passionate about this and
demonstrating and encouraging people why
it's in their interest and their
children's interests that we do these
things so
we need to do more on the narrative we
need to do more to
enable people to contribute to this
agenda
we need
to put out there the problems that need
solving and be more explicit about that
and incentivize people to come up with
those answers this is about the people
of this country delivering those targets
government
can do things to help and incentivize
and support and remove obstacles but
what will what will ensure this works
and what will ensure that legacy
is letting people contribute to that
mission are you expecting that xero to
push the tax burden up even higher
no i don't i don't think that is a a
foregone uh conclusion that's the
treasury's estimate isn't it
so
on our current trajectory i mean there
are clearly lots of disagreements about
our current trajectory and one of the
only moments of harmony uh in some of
the debates we've had have has been
about how
our ability to compete or lack of our
ability to compete in
the foreseeable future is is not
right for us uh we need to focus on
growth we need to focus on competition a
lot of the work i've been doing in trade
has been about enabling smart people
ideas and money to come together to
solve some of these problems
we are one of the the game-changing
nations in this respect
and although people look at our
our contribution to net zero and say
it's tiny in comparison to the world
it's not when you think about our
knowledge transfer our science base our
entrepreneurs
our legacy of working with other nations
to help them uh make that transition or
leapfrog uh
into
a modern economy and uh and ensuring
that they can meet their targets too
let's move on to another issue which is
of real interest and concern to
spectator readers in particular which is
the online safety bill do you support it
in its current format i do support the
bill i would want to make progress on it
but i do understand the concerns that
there are
around how you define particular things
in law
and
the
chilling effect that it might have on
freedom of speech
i think our government's got a good
track record on freedom of speech i
think that uh there's always more we can
do but we have taken a real stand and a
real grip on some of the issues
affecting particularly on campuses and
uh and elsewhere
i'm confident that we will be able to
put a bill through
that provides those reassurances but
clearly there are some pretty horrible
things that need to be gripped and
that's what the bill does so the issue
of concern for the spectator is that
well our argument is that it would
outlaw free speech by creating a new
category of legal but harmful
what does legal but harmful mean to you
so it is difficult to define this is the
weak point because it is difficult to
define these things in law because what
um uh you know what might offend one
person uh might be
perfectly right for another um and i
think unless you can really define that
in law uh there's a problem but we we do
have existing laws um where people are
causing real material harm to people
when people are stalked for example
that i think we could draw on but i do
recognize the need that any law we're
putting through
has to have clarity and if we can't
provide that clarity it's not going to
work so i'm prepared to look at those
issues someone being followed and
monitored online is is very different to
somebody being distressed as the bill
itself puts it in one of its clauses by
something that somebody else is saying
online i mean we all have our different
trigger points so
how would you protect that that's one of
the issues that one of your rivals kemi
badernock has has referred to the hurt
feelings clause i think she's put it as
yes but i i don't think this is about
hurt feelings i think this is about um
elements of
stalking or
causing really severe distress to people
but again uh
this bill is very targeted at
other issues
i think we also need to look at
the business model of some of the
platforms that we're talking about um
platforms that
one suspects
don't have real people on them and how
some of those accounts and bots are
being weaponized to uh to cause distress
or spreading misinformation um but i i
think the bottom line is unless you can
define this categorically in law it's
not going to be a good law
and therefore best not make it let's
talk about the union
are there any circumstances in which you
would agree to a second scottish
independence referendum i think this is
a settled question
we've recently had a referendum and
this is not uh going to be something
that i'm going to be looking at we we
have so many more priorities and i think
the people of scotland uh want us to
focus on the things that are of genuine
concern to them cost of living
uh ensuring that the scottish government
is actually delivering for them on
health care and other issues so uh no i
i'm not looking at that and your
predecessors have made
various attempts to try to strengthen
the case for the united kingdom panicked
trips over the border or not going over
the border depending on what the
scottish conservatives
ask of the the westminster leader
fluctuating union units within downing
street
so we talked about
the negative plan for the union i
suppose in terms of no second referendum
what's your positive plan for it
so
i think it's only really at times of
celebration or crisis that we pull
together as as the four nations
our diversity is actually a massive
strength just the
take the nhs how the different systems
work together which suits their their
local area it's actually a huge
potential and opportunity for learning
for for best practice so
the systems we have are good
i also think that our our culture and
it's about english regions as well as
the the devolved
uh um nations
we ought to celebrate that more because
i think although we say at the dispatch
box we talk about
tax dividends to scottish households
that's not really
what is going to hold the union together
it's the shared mutuality it's our
history uh it's our culture so i've been
really interested in uh looking at these
types of issues and i've interviewed a
lot of people myself including
the the dreaded bbc which is a
a much loved institution but doesn't
sometimes seem to love the country back
and looking at things that they've done
that work and
giving them ideas
i've campaigned as you know for the uk
theme to be brought back which sounds a
trivial thing but actually it was so
loved by everyone across the four
nations it was even played by
uh fishery protection vessels out over
the water to warn the french they were
around it was it was part of our our
culture and
it was written by a refugee and it was
his love letter to the nation wouldn't
it be amazing if we did if we if we had
a project to write the new uk scene i
think it's those sorts of things that
get people thinking get people excited
get people thinking about what it is
that we we are as a uh as a nation and
we ought to be doing more of that
uh and whitehall
ought to remember that it it is the
government of the united kingdom even
though some of its uh remit is in health
for example limited to england we should
talk about the united kingdom more would
you commit to going to scotland once a
month either yourself or taking the
cabinet up there i i think
the prime minister needs to travel i
think
other people have had all of my best
ideas i think listening to people who
know what's going on in their area is
really powerful and it also helps you
calibrate
your mind when you're looking at policy
that's that's coming up and forward
i think though that uh although you can
do those things you need a much more
steady drumbeat of
visits and in engagement and that is
hard because
whitehall is very centrifugal and it
pulls it pulls people in but i do think
that is important
and i certainly would see that being
part of my regular week now it's fair to
say that this contest has been quite
energetic in terms of the briefings and
the hustings
and so on you've complained yourself
about negative campaigning from other
camps you've all been tearing chunks out
of one another one way or another in in
this contest so i don't think i have
i mean you have been having a good
debate in the televised hosting we've
been having a good debate yeah i think
but that's i think that's part for the
course i think i mean
the first thing i said to my campaign
team is we would campaign as we would
govern
and it goes back to my
opener if we do not win an election
everything that we have worked for so
hard over the last few years will be for
nothing so we've got to come out of this
in good shape i hope the rest of the
contest will be about building a team
and and forging that and what an
opportunity you know sorry apologies to
the british public but they're going to
have a months of this
it's a month of the conservative party
on
uh send and receive and
that is an opportunity for us to
demonstrate that they should stay with
us that they're excited about our ideas
um and and that we're positive people
that want the best for the country so i
hope that's the kind of flavor of the
contest going forward going forward so
thus far do you think the contest has
damaged the tory brand
i think we've not been helped by some of
the
tv formats um i
i have conducted my campaign in a way
that i think is needed
and has been the right thing to do
now more than ever we've got to
restore some positivity and some
professionalism
to what we do and i
i think it's really important that we
don't just say we're going to do those
things we actually do them
what's the first thing you do to bring
the party back together after winning
so i think the thing that
makes my colleagues anxious is our
ability to deliver that's that's the
most pressing thing they want to see
people reducing the pressures on the nhs
and opening up access to healthcare by
christmas they want to see us make a
tangible difference to that they want us
to grip the cost of living issues and be
ahead of the curve on where we're going
to have to provide extra support
and so who is round the top table is
really important
cabinet i've said i'm going to have a
tighter cabinet it's currently
crazy how anyone could make a decision
with you know uh two football teams in
that room i don't know um
so a tighter cabinet empowered ministers
of state really really effective
government and reform uh in whitehall
i also think they they want to see the
party being brought together in terms of
the we've got so many caucuses and
clearly it's been
a contest to date where fault lines have
been stamped on
and we need to set out a vision that
will unite the party and we need to keep
them focused on what happens if we don't
unite and win the next general election
it's a difficult and large coalition to
hold together we have to remember that
our majority was won on the lowest
turnout for 100 years in very unique
circumstances but i think the platform
i've set out which is focused on the
real bread and butter issues for people
what their constituents are really
worried about
growth and competition and safety and
security at home is one that will reach
across blue wall red wall into all of
the parts of the united kingdom and
every demographic and certainly the the
thing that i'm very proud of in our
campaign is it appears to be having that
reach to the general public
penny warden thank you very much for
joining us thank you
well thank you rishi sunak for joining
us for our spectator hustings it's your
turn to give us your one minute opening
bid to be conservative leader
thanks isabel and thanks everyone for
listening the most important question
facing our country right now is how do
we get a grip of inflation and get our
economy growing quickly again now my
answer to that question is heavily
inspired by our party's greatest
post-war leader margaret thatcher
she rightly believed that inflation was
the ultimate enemy and
like her what i want to do is get a grip
of inflation now and not do anything
that would make it worse but i'll also
get the economy growing fast again by
undertaking a similar set of radical
reforms to her on the supply side i want
to cut eu regulations and unleash the
benefits of brexit i want to reform our
tax system to boost investment and
innovation and i will reshape our
education system because our children's
education today is our economy tomorrow
thank you for that and on to our first
topic which unsurprisingly is taxation
the big dividing line
in this leadership
contest you stand out from the other
candidates and have made a virtue of
doing so in that you are opposing tax
cuts now
uh are you actually sticking to exactly
the same tax and spend policy that
you've been pursuing under boris
johnson's premiership
so what i've tried to do throughout this
contest is be honest with with everybody
about how i see the economic challenges
we face and i think people deserve that
from their leaders and it's key to
restoring trust in politics
is that honesty now i think we have a
really significant challenge with
inflation and it's right that we grip it
as the number one priority inflation
makes everybody poorer it erodes savings
it reduces people's living standards it
pushes up mortgage rates
so my priority is to grip that and not
do anything that will make it worse
i will deliver tax cuts and will deliver
tax cuts that drive growth but i'll do
so in a way that's responsible
and that's what i believe as i said in
my opening pitch i believe that was what
margaret thatcher would have done and
she got that inflation was something
that you needed to get out of the system
and that would be my priority if elected
prime minister but i'll also make sure
that we drive growth in our economy and
do that by
reforming the taxes on investment and
innovation because that's how you get
growth and productivity it's making sure
that we drive those things
margaret thatcher did not see a
record-breaking tax burden though did
she taxes are at a 72-year high and
growth is flatlining so
how can you cite margaret thatcher when
that's our position at the moment
well margaret thatcher also didn't have
a once in a century pandemic to contend
with and that's why we're in the
situation that we're in now
we have to remember what happened in the
recession that we experienced because of
covid was
extraordinary our borrowing and our debt
went up to levels that we haven't seen
since world war ii and we had to do an
enormous amount to support the country
through that public services businesses
families
and i don't think anyone thought that we
wouldn't have to pay that back uh or
that that would have an impact on things
going forward and i think it's right to
just be honest about that and that's my
view and i think it's really important
as a moral issue that we get our
borrowing and debt under control
but also that is key to making sure that
we grip inflation and that my priority
is very much to deliver tax cuts we
actually started just this month by
raising the amount that you can earn
before
you pay any national insurance is a
really progressive tax cut for people uh
i've made sure that we will have an
income tax cut in this parliament that's
fully paid for in all the plans and this
autumn i've also set out plans already
to reform business taxation to boost
investment and to boost innovation and
those are the things that we need to do
if we want to unlock growth and you
talked about growth not being as
strong as we would like
i gave a lecture in in february this
year about my view on how to drive up
growth and a big part of the answer is
getting businesses to invest more and to
innovate more and i know that we can
reform our tax system to do that and
i'll deliver that in the autumn
now one thing you haven't mentioned in
all of that is making government smaller
that was something you talked about a
lot when you were a backbencher have you
changed your mind since being in
government
absolutely not and you know i think the
state should be strong but it should
also be nimble and as
dynamic as possible
what we need to do is get away from a
mentality where we focused
you know a lot on what we were spending
and what we were announcing and we need
to focus a bit more on what we're
getting for that
and making sure that we're prepared to
go and reform things and drive up
productivity in the public sector so
that the
outcomes people see their experience of
seeing their gp getting their driving
license making sure social care works
for them having crime reducing their
communities all those things they
actually see very clear change on and
that would be my priority is about
delivery it's about being willing to do
some different things being willing to
challenge consensus
and
change leadership as required in public
services better use of technology and
data
and get better outcomes for people and
we know that that works if you look at
one of the great achievements of the
conservative government since 2010 you
know for me it's the education reforms
that michael gove and nick gibb and
others uh managed to get through
and that didn't require more money that
required a way of working that was
different and there's a challenging
consensus reforming public services and
now millions of children are better off
as a result and learning more as a
result you know i think that to me shows
what conservatism at its best can do
when it when it comes to public services
and that's the example i'd like to
emulate
okay well let's move on to our next
topic which is climate change and net
zero are you committed to the 2050 net
zero target
and i i come at this
first and foremost as a as a dad and i
have two young girls
and they don't ask enormous amount about
my job for the most part they're not
that bothered but the one thing they do
ask me about is what i'm doing on the
environment and on climate change and as
i think that's a very conservative thing
to care about you know i care very much
as a conservative about the inheritance
that we leave our kids and grandkids
you know that the inheritance we leave
them on the public finance is important
to me but equally i think the
environment that we leave them is also
important so i you know that's why i
believe that we should get there but i
also believe that we should get there in
a way that carries people with us
and there's no point trying to do
something where we can't
have broad support for it and that means
not necessarily running there the
fastest or the hardest or doing so in a
way that is not positive we've got to
make this about
how
the innovation that that transition will
bring is going to be positive for people
how it's going to lower their bills how
it's going to create jobs and prosperity
in parts of the country that maybe
haven't seen as much of it in the past
and i think if we can make it about
those things we can bring people with us
so to be clear you don't want britain to
be a world leader in tackling climate
change
i think we we already are if you look at
our carbon
emission reductions over the past 20 30
years we've decarbonized our economy
faster than any other large economy
and as you saw from our leadership of
cop last year
we've also demonstrated leadership in
lots of other areas and of the agenda
but i think we need to make sure when it
comes to these quite crunchy questions
of of how we do things in a way that
impacts our economy you know we're doing
that in a balanced way and there are
ways that we want to lead for example we
want to lead on innovation and
pioneering the new technologies that are
going to help us make the transition but
we need to have a mind as well about
what's happening around us so that we
don't
damage our economy disproportionately
in our path to net zero i think that's a
very reasonable approach to take
so i suppose one of the ways in which a
lot of candidates a lot of spectator
readers might argue would damage the
economy is if green taxes taxes to fund
reaching net zero more widely
go up surely given the treasury the
department you until recently led
estimates the cost of net zero is going
to be 60 billion pounds a year that's
going to have to add to the tax burden
well i think there's a couple of things
on green levees there are lots of people
who think green taxes should be removed
from energy bills and that sounds
appealing
for sure but those those levies actually
go and pay for specific things they pay
for energy that we're all benefiting
from at the moment and in particular
they pay for offshore wind which and
thankfully is now much more affordable
uh as a source of energy than it was a
decade ago as a result of the innovation
that's happened
so when people say they want to scrap
these green levees or green taxes
that what that means is they're going to
borrow money to do that or they're going
to put up taxes somewhere else
and
that's worth billions of pounds a year
so i guess the question for the people
who want to scrap them is where's that
money coming from were you just you
putting up taxes elsewhere are you
adding to our borrowing
now in terms of putting
an estimate on the cost of net zero i
think it is hard to put
a single figure and i know the treasury
has published various scenarios in the
past but the reason it's difficult to
say
this is the number is because of
innovation and the technologies that are
going to help us get there
are changing radically by the year
the cost and offshore wind is a great
example a decade ago offshore wind power
costs about 140 pounds of an hour and
now it's down to 40 pounds and you can
see the same with electric batteries
where the costs have come down
dramatically over the course of the last
several years and that's happening
across the board
and if you look at all parts of our
energy transition there's an incredible
amount of
innovation happening often led by
british scientists british research
british companies and that's great
because that ultimately means british
jobs and british prosperity that's why i
think this can be a positive thing but
it's why it's also hard to say with
great certainty well it's going to cost
this amount
and in terms of great certainty are you
prepared to pledge that the overall tax
burden won't go up as a result of your
government's attempts to meet net zero
i mean my my priority is to cut taxes
right of course i want to cut taxes i'm
a conservative i want people to keep
more of what they earn i want businesses
to be encouraged to invest and to
innovate i want to boost the economy in
the long run you know i want to deliver
all those things and i will deliver all
those things and actually i set out a
tax plan
earlier this year when i was still
chancellor that that explained how we
were going to do all those things and
what taxes we were going to cut what i'm
saying is i just want to do that
responsibly i want to make sure we get a
grip of inflation because that is the
economic priority now that if we don't
get a grip of it now it will cost
families much more in the long run and
that is not something that we should be
doing and you know once we've got that
under control i'm confident i can
deliver that tax plan and confident that
people's taxes can start falling
let's move on to our next topic which is
the online safety bill do you support it
in its current form
so again i come at this first as a as a
parent and i as i mentioned i have two
young girls who are at the age where
they're starting to go online more
and you know that's
that's
i've got to tell you i'm i'm quite
worried about all of that and i sit down
with my my wife and we talk about it i'm
concerned about what they
could end up looking at and i think the
exposure to explicit sometimes horrific
material at such a young age is wrong
and we've got to find a way to protect
children against that in the same way as
we do in the offline world so to speak
so that that's my first start so i think
we do need to to have something that
does that
but with the bill i think the challenge
we've got and that's why i'm glad the
government's paused the bill so we can
refine our approach here that the
challenge is whether it strays in the
into the territory of suppressing free
speech
and
the bit in particular that that has
caused some concern and questions is
around this area where the government is
saying look here's some content that's
legal um
but harmful
and it's uh that that's this kind of
area which i think people rightly have
said what exactly does that mean and
that's the bit that i would want as
prime minister to go and look at to to
make sure that we get that right
so you're pledging to potentially scrap
the legal but harmful section
and again i know you're trying to push
me into the direction of getting a firm
pledge what i'm saying is i i do think
we need to have a way to protect
children against harm as i said and i
say that first and foremost as a as a
parent but i do want to make sure that
we are also protecting free speech and
the legal
but harmful bit is is the one that i
would want to spend some time as prime
minister going over and making sure that
we're getting that bit exactly right and
i can't tell you the right what you know
what the right answer at the end of that
process will be but i think it's fair
that people have raised some concerns
about that and its impact on free speech
and i think it's right that those
concerns are proper
okay thank you
we'll move on to the united kingdom and
holding the union together are there any
circumstances in which you would agreed
a second scottish independence
referendum
but this is
this process is now
playing out in the courts and the
supreme court will
make a decision you know i you know
you know
i think uh i i hope that they will they
will decide that you know it's rightly
for the constitution it sets out how
that's meant to work so that call
process will play out my general
view on the matter is i i care very
deeply about the union and i think of
all the challenges we've got ahead of us
now i think most people
in scotland especially would agree that
that's not the priority right now is to
have a divisive referendum the priority
for
all governments that represent them and
administrations who represent them is to
tackle the economic challenges that
they're facing with the cost of living
and that's what i certainly will be
focused on doing and you know i don't
think arguing about another referendum
now is remotely the right priority
and so what would you be doing
positively to strengthen the case for
the union given the reason the snp are
pursuing the idea of a second
independence referendum is in part
because there is still a significant
proportion of the scottish population
that at any time favors another
referendum and indeed independence
yeah i think
what the uk government can do
is demonstrate
on the ground in scotland and wales and
northern ireland how it is making a
difference to people's lives
and we've started doing much more of
that through things like the leveling up
fund where
the uk government is talking directly to
communities in scotland and then
delivering change in those communities
that's that's been something that we've
done that's new and i think it is
working really well
and it's changed the conversation and
people can see very clearly
some of the some of the benefits that
result from that
i think another thing we can do is
talk emotionally about it um you know
it's you know you can make practical
cases of
for the union and economic cases but
actually to me it's it's much more
emotive than that it's about the values
that bind us as a united kingdom and i
don't think we should be afraid of
making that emotional argument for the
united kingdom uh from the heart as well
as the practical um argument for it and
demonstrating it and that's what i'd
like to try and do and where would you
be doing that would you be spending a
lot of time in scotland yourself there
have been times when
previous tory leaders have not
necessarily been welcomed north of the
border
yeah i mean i think people can already
see that i take
that seriously i mean i was the
chancellor who set up a
economic campus for the government and
for the treasury in darlington
and
not only did i set it up and it's going
was going incredibly well when i left
and i'm sure it still is
i also spent a lot of time there myself
personally and ensure that all my
ministers also did uh in the department
because it's not enough just to set up
these things actually if you want to
demonstrate that they matter to you
being there is really important and i've
already changed how the department works
in in my own small way as chancellor for
our northern campus and you would expect
me to
to do i think something similar with
regard to the union you know i'd want to
be in all parts of the union making the
positive case for it and engaging with
people i mean that's part of the job but
it's a part of the job that i do take
seriously as people hopefully can
have seen how i did it as chancellor
all right well on to our final question
which is on keeping the party together
having talked about keeping the united
kingdom
together do you think that this
leadership contest has been good for the
conservative party both in terms of
public perception and in terms of
your colleagues having much of a chance
of getting on with one another in the
coming months
well i you know i think it's always good
to debate ideas right and that is
something that is
it's good it's refreshing it's important
that we have those debates and it and it
makes sure that we challenge ourselves
and we're getting everything right
as we figure out the right
agenda to present to the country so that
part of it is healthy and is and is good
but i think also it demonstrates the
enormous
range of talent that we've got in the
party right there's you know i've been
really proud to stand on platforms with
my colleagues it it demonstrates i think
the breadth and variety
of
talent that we've got and demonstrates
to me that the conservative party really
is the party of opportunity and
aspiration and i think actually to take
a moment to
reflect on that is is worth doing and we
should be afraid to champion that
and i think whoever wins
will
try very hard to unite the party for me
that's about building a team that draws
on all the traditions and talents
of our party which is a broad church
putting the best people in the jobs and
continuing to conduct the rest of the
campaign
in an incredibly positive tone which
i've i've tried to do so far so i think
you know i i think that's all entirely
doable but the main thing is to reflect
on the fact we've got some fantastic
people at the top of the conservative
party and everyone should be really
proud of that and excited about the
future as a result
so what's the first thing you'll do
on becoming conservative leader to try
to unite the party you talk about
getting a you know good team around you
getting lots of different people into
into your cabinets what's what's the
priority in terms of healing some of the
wounds that have opened up recently
i think it's what i said it's actually
the
one of the first things you do is is put
a team together as prime minister it's a
very visible
demonstration of your commitment to
delivering what i said which is drawing
on all the
talents of all the wings and traditions
in our party and putting fantastic
people
around you to help you deliver for the
country and so i think that is by far
away the most important priority at the
beginning and
how we will bring people together and
serve the british people to the best of
our ability
and would that include liz truss and
penny mordant
i i've i've been particularly careful as
i i assume the others have been as well
not to get into the the
the business of starting to talk about
specific jobs and specific people but
you know as i've been very public about
in all the platforms i've been on and on
telly as well i i've got nothing but
enormous respect and admiration for all
of the people who stood in this contest
and i've been very public about that and
as i said earlier to you as well we've
got some fantastic people all of whom
bring something
unique and special to the contest to
government to the party and as a general
thing
i think any leader would want to draw on
the fullest range of talents that that
thank you so much for joining us at our
hustings
well liz trust thank you so much for
joining us for our spectator hustings so
it's over to you to give us your one
minute opening bid to be conservative
leader we're only a difficult situation
as a country we're facing the biggest
war we've seen on european shores for
a generation we also face a massive
economic crisis we only have two years
before the next general election to get
our economy back on track as well as
making sure we continue to stand up to
putin in ukraine
i'm the candidate with a bold plan
to reduce taxes to unleash growth across
our country to level up in a
conservative way through new investment
zones and i've shown that i can deliver
at the foreign office i've stood up to
vladimir putin putting on the toughest
package of sanctions delivered the nip
bill to parliament and at trade i struck
dozens of trade deals even though people
said it wouldn't be possible including
with countries like japan and australia
i'm ready from day one
thank you on to our first topic which is
the key dividing line in this contest
tax cuts
so tell us about your proposals for tax
cuts are they significant how are you
going to pay for them
i think it's very important that in the
difficult economic
scenario we're in now
we don't raise taxes because raising
taxes will choke off growth it'll make
us harder for us to pay our debt back
later
what i propose is reversing the national
insurance increase it was a manifesto
commitment that we wouldn't increase
national insurance i think we should
fulfill that i also don't want to
increase corporation tax because we need
to attract the investment to drive
business and growth right across our
country i'd also have a temporary
marital moratorium on the green levy
cutting money from people's energy bills
all of those tax cuts are affordable
within our current
fiscal position we'd still be able to
pay debts down
over three years but what we wouldn't be
doing
is immediately trying to balance the
books following covert which has been a
massive economic shock
so it sounds like you're not
particularly worried about how this is
going to be paid for
no that's not true at all i am very
clear it can be paid for
within the existing
fiscal envelope the
the taxes that i'm cutting
cost 30 billion pounds
that is affordable and what i'm saying
is that if we raise taxes now that will
lead to lower revenues which will make
it harder to balance the books in future
you don't get growth by increasing tax
and you're not worried as rishi sunaka's
has repeatedly argued that this will
lead to even higher inflation
the best way to control inflation is
monetary policy we already know that
inflation is due to fall next year
i want to see a tougher bank of england
mandate in the future whilst keeping the
bank independent but my tax cuts will
actually help grow the supply side of
the economy which will relieve
inflationary pressures so you don't
think the bank of england is doing its
current job that well
the bank of england mandate was last set
in 1997 in completely different economic
times what i'm saying is we need to look
at it again and make sure it's fit for
purpose and benchmark it against
international independent banks okay
well you mentioned the green levy so
let's move on to net zero our next topic
are you committed to the 2050 target i
am committed to the net zero target but
i want to achieve it in a way that
doesn't penalize businesses and families
how is that possible
well first of all i would have a
moratorium on the green energy levy
while we look at alternative ways of
delivering net zero have you ever
i'm a free enterprise environmentalist i
believe in de delivering environmental
goals through enterprise and attracting
investment into the uk yes we do have
time to do it
the temporary moratorium is affordable
i'd put it on general taxation
and i would immediately have a spending
review and budget and also have a
long-term plan to reform the public
sector and most importantly to get
growth up in our economy the problem
we've got as a country is we've had
relatively low growth for about well
several decades and until we fix that
problem until we
carry out the reforms to regulation we
need to carry out until we're able to
get more pension funds into high-tech
businesses and
create jobs and opportunities around the
country we're not going to be able to
pay for
uh government spending and we're
certainly not going to be able to put
more money in people's pockets so growth
has to be our number one priority and so
are you pledging that meeting net zero
is not going to add to the tax burden
you know the treasury has estimated that
the costs of net zero will be 60 billion
pounds a year so how can you keep that
away from taxation i'm going to review
how we deliver net zero i think we can
do it in a more
market-friendly way i also think it's
very important that we're not simply
exporting our carbon production so we
need to look at the whole issue of
carbon leakage i would have a thorough
review of that and also make more use of
transition fuels like gas because we
know
that people are struggling with energy
bills at the moment we need to do all we
can to get the transition right so we
are able to
get to net zero in a cost effective way
so is that a is that a pledge not to add
to the tax burden or do you think that
taxes may have to go up
my overall plan on taxation is first of
all to have a thorough review of tax and
simplify our taxes they're far too
complicated i want to make tax better
for families so if you take time out of
work to have a child or you're looking
after elderly relatives i want to make
the tax system better and simpler for
you and within that context of course we
have to deliver our environmental
objectives but you can't separate out
the different bits of the tax system
what i can say though is having the
highest taxes for 70 years is a problem
and it's a drag on growth and we have to
deal with that we have to get growth up
through supply-side reform as well and
you mentioned as one of your pledges
around the environment and climate a
nature
survey which would look at the state of
biodiversity in this country one of the
things a lot of ecologists are worried
about is that tree planting has become
such a religion that it's actually
contributing to environmental
destruction is that something you worry
about i mean your own party has made
some some pretty big pledges on trees in
the past few years well certainly i
remember making a pledge on trees when i
was uh environment secretary so and
trees are good you know trees are a
carbon sink there are they're also
important industry actually i rep i
represent the constituents there's a lot
of forestry uh in it so
we need to look at what is appropriate
for britain and what my concern is
is the european natural habitats
directive was based on what are the
endangered species across the whole of
europe we need something that's much
more specific to britain that is
protecting the endangered species but
not necessarily causing massive problems
for building for relatively common
species that's that's what i want to do
so it's about
helping the economy grow whilst
protecting the environment at the same
time
now obviously you are unlikely to be
prime minister in 2050 um so how will
you hold yourself accountable to the net
zero target
in the interim in the time that you have
in government because it's so easy for
politicians to
really abandon these targets in practice
and leave it to the next government to
deal with well once i've completed this
review of how we achieve net zero i will
publish that and show how we will get to
net zero but what i want is the
opportunity to look at it thoroughly in
the round make sure we're achieving it
in the most efficient way
okay we'll move on now to
the online safety bill which is another
topic spectator readers are particularly
exercised about do you support it in its
current format
i'm a believer in freedom of speech i
also believe that we need to protect
particularly under 18s
from harm
and
what i want to make sure with the bill
and i know it's now going to the house
of lords
is that
it it strikes the balance correctly
between between those two things and do
you think it does at the moment
i need to look into more detail about
exactly how it is implemented and have
discussions with my colleagues but the
principles i believe in are the
protection of free speech but also
making sure
that we're not exposing under 18s to
harm online and you know i've got two
teenage daughters
i am very very concerned about the
effect particularly social media has on
teenage girls or mental health so i will
want to look at that
and make sure that that is
in in the right place as well as
protecting freedom of speech freedom of
the press i'm a great i'm a great
believer that those are core freedoms
that a healthy society depends on
there's a big difference there isn't
there between
social media
outlets that promote eating disorders
that display sexually explicit content
and so on and
one of the things that the spectator is
particularly worried about in the bill
which is this new category of legal but
harmful which we think is going to
basically outlaw legal free
speech could do you know what legal but
harmful means
well i think i think there's more
there's more nuance in the bill
than
than that isabel but i'd be very keen to
talk to the spectator and others to make
sure the bill delivers what we want it
to deliver and
this is a complicated error i speak to
colleagues around the world who are
looking at how to
legislate
for
online spaces
the fundamental principle is the rules
should be the same
online as they are in real life i think
that's a that's a fundamental principle
and that's what i will make sure
i apply but as i've said i want to have
a thorough look at it to make sure it
delivers the objectives i've set out you
don't agree with the hurt feelings
characterization that some of your
fellow candidates have used to describe
this bill well i as i've said i need to
look at exactly you know these
these issues aren't necessarily
complex and nuanced and
i think there is a place for
further amendments to this legislation
to make sure we're delivering it and
also
make sure that everybody is aware of the
intention of the bill as well which is
also important so i'm committed to doing
that but i think i've set out very
clearly the principles i believe in okay
well we'll move on now to preserving the
united kingdom are there any
circumstances in which you would agree
to a second scottish independence
referendum no
none at all
well
the last referendum in 2014 was
described as a once-in-a-generation
referendum and we're now in 2022 that is
not a generation ago
and yet the question doesn't seem to
have been settled in the opinion polls
does its support for scottish
independence goes up and down but there
is still a significant
significant proportion of the scottish
population who are in favor of it or of
another referendum so in terms of the
positive case for the united kingdom
what would you as prime minister do to
make that
well i'm a i'm a child of the union i
was brought up in paisley and scotland
and in leeds and
you know it's a very important part of
our dna as a country you know we're a
family
that's the way i see it and
the approach
i would take and it's the approach i've
taken in government is we need to say
we're a government for the whole of the
united kingdom
i'm putting more senior foreign office
and staff in to make sure that we have
people to have consular rep
to deal with overseas consulates uh in
edinburgh for example
i've done a lot of work on trade
getting the scotch whiskey tariffs
removed
which has had a really positive impact
on distilleries across scotland so
it's about demonstrating that the uk
government is delivering for all parts
of the united kingdom that's the reason
i was so keen to
put the
northern ireland protocol bill forward
because without that bill
we wouldn't have seen you know
the the end to the very difficult
situation northern ireland we haven't
had an executive since february and the
bill is absolutely crucial to protecting
our union we'll come onto northern
ireland in a second but just to stick
with scotland um briefly would you be
holding more cabinet meetings up in
scotland would you commit to going to
scotland i don't know once a month as
prime minister there have been sort of
varying levels of attention paid to
scotland by
uh the uh your previous prime ministers
in the conservative party i mean at one
point it was suggested that it wasn't a
good idea for boris johnson to come
north of the border would you
well i regular trip i go to scotland
regularly i love it because
as i said i went to primary school in in
paisley so it's very it's very fun to me
do scots love you
well that's that's a question for scots
probably some scots love me i can tell
you that um
but
the important point is
not about how many meetings we have and
how many visits we do which of course
are important and it's an important part
of ministry of life is what we actually
deliver for people you know are people's
lives
better do they have more opportunity
are we unleashing the
talent
uh that's that's what's important so and
that's true in paisley as much as it is
in leeds or or belfast or or cardiff so
what what i am about as a politician is
i'm a politician that gets things done
and i will deliver for the people of
scotland as i you know want to deliver
for the people of the whole united
kingdom and that that will be my focus
and approach and i'll look at things on
a uk basis first i think that's very
important now you've said in this
leadership contest that the party has
moved on from 2016 but in the eu
referendum debate in that year there
wasn't that much discussion of the
impact on northern ireland was there do
you regret that obviously you're on the
remain side but you've made very clear
that you've done everything you can to
deliver brexit opportunities but do you
think it came as a shock to everyone in
government the implications for northern
ireland of brexit what we've put forward
in the protocol bill
is a positive solution that works for
northern ireland and make sure there's a
free flow of trade through red and green
lanes and also protects the eu single
market because it gives the eu the
information they need the data they need
to be able to
protect a single market we're also
putting in place
rigorous controls so if there is a
violation of moving things outside
northern ireland
we can deal with that so this this
problem
is entirely soluble
there is a solution my preference is to
have a negotiated solution with the eu
but what we put forward in our bill is a
solution that works so this issue
absolutely can be resolved okay well
finally the only thing fiercer than the
heat outside as we record this
is the leadership contest itself which
has become very energetic there's been a
lot of complaints about negative
campaigning you said you're running a
holy positive campaign but the truth is
that all of you been tearing chunks out
of one another after what has been quite
a long period of real instability for
your party so what's the first thing you
do to bring the party back together
well first of all it's vital that we
have a vision and a plan that people can
unite around and my
team of supporters is made up of people
from right across
the conservative party all parts of the
conservative party and in my time as the
foreign secretary i've engaged
all parts of the conservative party also
the labour party the liberals other
parties as well i do a lot of mp
briefings i do a lot of discussion and i
think that's important it's important
that when we do new pieces of
legislation for example one of the
things i want to do is abolish the
top-down housing targets it's important
we consult with people about what the
next steps are so the way to
bring people together
is to have a care plan and really listen
and engage and have a two-way
conversation we've got lots of talented
people in the conservative party i want
to make the best use of all of their
talents and we all share the same
fundamental desire whichever you need
caucus or group we're in and lots of
people had lots of groups that i
discovered from all the hustings i've
done
but whatever we all want britain to
succeed we all want
people across the country to
have more opportunities to get a great
education to have great local services
to be able to start their own business
that's you know we're an aspiration
party and i think that's a vision you
know the vision of the aspiration nation
that we can unite behind you pulled out
of the televised hustings this week
because of the ten of the televised
debate at least
do you think that the contest so far has
damaged the tory brand
i think it's good that we are having a
discussion and there are real issues
being discussed you talked about taxes
as well and that's one of the issues
we're discussing it's good for parties
to have those types of discussion
uh
i'd rather have them internally but the
modern world doesn't always work like
that social media doesn't work like that
they're too nosy and uh westminster
often doesn't work like that
the important thing is you know we make
a clear decision about as a party about
our direction you know we have the
debate with with our members and then we
move on and deliver and we all get
behind
the new leader that's that's what's
important and i think
when people are thinking about how to
vote an election they don't vote about
the past they vote about the future and
sometimes i look at you know have you
delivered are your promises credible
but really what they're waiting on is
the future and that's what we need to be
focused on so do you think the tory
brand is in a negative or a positive
place at the moment it's in a positive
place it's in a positive place i mean
look
i'm not in any way saying what's what's
gone on has been perfect but you know we
got a major mandate in 2019 people were
fed up particularly in parts of the
north of england they were fed up with
years and years of labor failure and
neglect and that's why they voted
conservative for something fresh what we
have to do now and we've got two years
to do it is deliver and that's what i'm
about
that's going to be quite difficult
though i mean two years is not a long
time in politics at all is it it's
difficult but i am up for the challenge
i've shown that i can be tough i'm shown
that i can get things through whitehall
and i will deliver
liz trust thank you very much for
joining us
well thank you so much for watching
those interviews and if you are a
politics addict you really should sign
up to my evening blend email it's the
best read politics newsletter in
westminster it's got full analysis and
roundup of what has happened in the days
politics and a diary on what to expect
next sign up at spectator dot co dot uk
forward slash blend